foreign
hey Jamie welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me hey thanks for
calling how can we help
um I know taxes is around the corner and
I'm almost done paying off my car
um I'm thinking about paying off my card
and uh putting the rest in a high-yield
savings account I just I just discovered
those so just wanted to see if that was
a good idea
well do you have any debt
uh just the just the car and then I'm
then I'm done I already paid off my
credit card last year thank goodness
awesome huh what's left on the car
what was the what what's left on the car
loan
uh 3 000. okay how much money do you
have in the bank
uh he took a hit doing some car repairs
so right now I have about 700 in the
bank okay and your what was your
question
um with with the taxes I'm thinking I
might get four thousand in tax return
I'm thinking I should just go ahead and
take out that car note and then put the
rest in a savings account or
okay so let's say in April you get a
return of four thousand you've got three
thousand left on the car loan that
leaves you with a thousand and that
would leave you with Seventeen hundred
dollars in the bank
correct yeah okay
well that would be my plan is pay off
that debt ASAP
okay just knock it out yeah just knock
it out because the next step in the baby
steps is to build that fully funded
emergency fund so you'll be able to
knock out baby step two pay off all your
debt and then start working to build up
to that three to six months in expenses
so that's pretty exciting and Jamie
here's here's another piece of the
puzzle that I want to challenge you with
could you pay off the car before you get
the tax return and you can use that
towards your emergency fund
um I don't know if I could do it before
what's your income like
um I only make about about 45k a year
okay and all of that money where is it
going are you doing a monthly budget
yeah I'm I'm just now starting the
budget I had it really dial back on
eating out and that that was probably my
biggest one that's the kicker the car
yeah the car repair the eating out was
constant but the car repair hurt we had
to like put 400 into car repairs
um who's winning is there a spouse
yeah okay so what's your total household
income
uh total I would say 60 all together
so your spouse is making about 15 are
they part-time what are they doing
they're they're part-time they only work
three days a week about is there a way
to increase that
um what's holding them back kids
the kids and they they care to be honest
daycare is just it's just too expensive
so we try to avoid it with our schedules
okay so your spouse stays home
yeah and then for three days
um she does go in it's you know the
later on when I'm home so okay and the
other piece when you get a tax return
here's the issue I have with it you're
giving the government a interest-free
loan all year long with that money so
another goal I have for you is to stop
getting such a large refund and I also
wouldn't Bank on getting a big refund
this year because the with the tax
changes that have come down the pike
they have gotten rid of all the expanded
child tax credit all the expansions that
were you know due to the economic impact
that was happening with the pandemic is
gone and so are you banking on this 4
000 how sure are you it's going to be
that number
uh I'm I'm doing a low low guesstimate
no I think the lowest it will be is is
four thousand it could be 3 000 but I I
am pretty sure it'll be around there
okay well I wouldn't plan for it I would
pretend live your life as if this car
debt is is needing to come from your
future income and attack that thing with
a Vengeance even if it means working
overtime Selling Stuff continuing to
slash your expenses uh just in case that
tax refund comes in low and now you're
like oh gosh now I'm defeated because I
thought I was going to be debt free
and so that's how I would approach it
and I would also maybe work on changing
your withholdings with your employer to
get closer to zero where you don't owe
anything and you're not refunded much
is that is that the better option to
just to zero it out not to get anything
back and not to pay yes because that
means you paid just the right amount of
taxes instead of paying too much or not
enough if it's not enough you owe money
if it's too much you get the refund
that's how taxes work it's not a gift
from Uncle Sam
okay so I just been paying too much okay
exactly that makes sense and what what
about those uh go ahead no keep going
I was going to ask I just discovered
um Alley Bank oh Ally yes
those those are scams are there no no
those are legitimate Banks Here's the
the magic word you want to see on any of
these websites is FDIC and that is
federal insurance that backs that bank
in case they go under your money is
protected up to 250 000 per person on
the account
okay and so Ally is a legitimate Bank uh
there's a lot of other high-yield
savings accounts out there the ones you
don't want to go with is the ones that
have credit card companies attached to
it because what that really means is
that high-yield savings account is just
a gateway drug to get you into their
debt products so stay away from those
and they can be especially tempting too
because a lot of them have slightly
higher rates simply to draw you in like
George said they want you to be in their
system so therefore you're more likely
to get into debt so that's such a good
call out George because we personally
just moved our housing fund into a high
yield savings account and
um it was really tempting we had that
conversation off air where it was like
well is it ethically wrong to go with a
major credit card company that has a
savings account
um and it's just important to think
through that absolutely what kind of
marketing are you going to get from that
but yeah thanks so much for the call
Jamie wishing you the best with the car
payoff it's exciting you're so close 3
000 bucks left then the emergency fund
then you got Financial Peace because you
don't owe anyone anything you've got a
pile of money in the bank and you sleep
better at night and it turns out you're
less concerned about what's happening in
the white house because your house is
okay and that's all that matters at the
end of the day absolutely you can't
control Congress
God bless as we have seen in the last
year but it's a good reminder Christina
for those I'm getting a lot of questions
about high-yield savings accounts lately
because a lot of people they're
comfortable with their Bank they've got
their savings it's making pretty much
nothing and right now interest rates on
savings accounts have skyrocketed and so
I think I'm getting like 3.8 right now
there's some bonuses and things like
that you can get so you can get upwards
of three four percent right now so it's
it may be time to move that money into a
new online high-yield savings account so
that you can you know you want it to
grow a little bit never hurts yeah it's
always exciting now we have our money in
that high yield savings account and
we've been getting emails every few
weeks saying hey it's gone up half a
percent that's a nice feeling that's
nice and you can store most of your
emergency phone there I like to keep a
little bit in my checking account as
above first you have immediate access to
it instead of having to wait you know a
day but it's a great option to see your
money grow we love that